we told you within the last hour that  the English Football League had agreed  to suspend all matches until the 3rd of  April we are now being told that  following suit the FA the Premier League  the AFL and Barclays FA Women's Super  League and also the FA Women's  Championship have all collectively  agreed now to postpone the professional  game in England until the 3rd of April  at the very earliest the action which  will be kept under constant review has  been taken of course due to the  increasing numbers of clubs that are  taking steps to isolate their players  and their staff because of the kovat 19  virus remember they're members of the  Premier League teams Everton also  Arsenal who are in that self-isolation  because of either known infected players  or suspected infected players